there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock what's up y'all it's episode
138 mm-hmm it's Friday night as we're
recording this that's right I got my
groove on he's got his cuckoo cuckoo
gone I got my what is this a screwdriver
yes screwdriver cool the Merritt large
screwdriver Lord Kukulcan has not
revealed him set himself yet to me but
he probably will he's gonna reveal
himself just started yeah this is
warming up for this show you know yeah I
had a I had a busy day so you know I'm
just trying to unwind had it rode up to
the VA rode a motorcycle all day yeah
you know to get there yeah such a rough
life amen
I'm gonna put on a blood pressure
medicine I know I know I was afraid that
they would be telling you manage its
genetic every month everybody my family
has it they don't die from it yeah you
know it must be because I've always had
super super low blood pressure
yeah because it my mother said it both
my grandparents on her side you know her
parents had it and she has it
yeah and both of her parents died they
didn't die you know they were ancient
yeah they didn't have they lived a long
time there was a [ __ ] thousand years
old just like some [ __ ] out of a Tolkien
book and they didn't die of anything
related to heart problems or yeah I
think some people can have just because
like I've known people that had really
high cholesterol it didn't really seem
to like give them heart disease or
anything like some people are built for
that high cholesterol runs in my family
though yeah I really have to watch it
like with the eating dairy and meat yeah
I think mine might be high but they know
that that blood pressure I knew was high
last year I knew that yeah didn't always
used to be that I all this lifting I'm
doing maybe it'll come back down I don't
know yeah we'll see
like I said mines always been super
awhile you know my whole entire life I'm
feeling different yeah that's true well
we'll see we'll see you
medication works five diet people you
know here to show on without me she just
she put a cardboard cutout of me here
and then I'll just say that that might
be that might make yourselves right
don't you might be dead two weeks from
now oh don't say that
mags it would no you already did say it
now you have to say something else so
like counteract it but yeah so anyway um
yeah we're doing at 138 doing another
true crime thing and I think this topic
has been requested a couple times and
we've actually mentioned it a few times
I think you mentioned him I like on a
show a long time ago but you couldn't
remember his name this is serial killer
Dean Corll yeah you tell me I knew who
this is but I can't really place the
cases when you start telling me what it
is uh yeah he started describing you
know what's interesting is that he seems
like this is another one of those ones
where it seems like he's not really a
household name I mean this [ __ ] happened
like in the early 70s
he's not really a household name but at
the time that he was killed he wasn't
apprehended he was killed
spoiler alert um I want to physical is's
oh oh yeah okay I know you talked about
yeah this bad [ __ ]
that's right it was at the time yeah he
had the highest body count of the time
she's the one killing all the boys right
yeah yeah this guy's bad and I'm always
kind of wondering too like they also
called him the Candyman which for
reasons which will become clear later on
so I always wondered if this might have
been maybe not maybe it's too late but I
was like is this the genesis of you know
the creepy guy and the white van giving
you free candy and training in because
he did that I remember this guy I
remember this case well I just forgot
this guy's name yeah yeah but that's
with all the bodies cuz you were - yeah
I forgot what his name was you better
more than the other shows and I think
one of the one of our you know people
commented in the on YouTube that it's
like oh you're talking about Dean Corll
and I was like
we should do a show about that summer
finally because mentioning a bunch of
interviews over the years and he was
mentioned in some books that I read over
the years so yeah I mean I remember the
the I remember some of the details well
actually I remember a lot of the details
of the case I just forgot the names
involved yeah you know and they think
that he killed at least 28 people yes
and it's found and it's probable that he
killed yeah and they found most of them
underneath that [ __ ] well they they were
like in four different locations yeah
but they think that he might have killed
some like before the iconic cuz like I
said he'd been doing this for a long
time and they wouldn't have caught him
while they didn't catch him like I said
but they wouldn't have known about it
unless one of his accomplices hadn't
like [ __ ] gunned him down he had he
had photos of people some of them never
never identified he had a photo of a
little kid chained to a board yeah yeah
next to our tool box yeah a tortured
more yeah yeah and I never did figure
out who that kid was yeah that's that
that's why they think that there's more
victims that took place before his
accomplices came on this thing spooky
[ __ ] how do you how do you abduct and
torture and murder some of these little
boys prob about seven or eight maybe
maybe like yeah most of his victims were
in their teens
yeah this was about seven or eight but
yeah you might have how could you how
could you do it with a kid like that and
then not have anybody look for that kid
or recognize that kid's photo the weird
thing about this too is that this seems
to be a case where because almost all of
his victims were from this one
particular like area of Houston Texas
and it was kind of a lower income you
know lower middle income sort of area of
white trash area ya know yeah so I'm
saying that it seemed like all these
boys were going missing but like the
cops were like guy they just run away
you know how like those poor kids do or
whatever so it's like they really didn't
link all of them together what was it
actually was a time there was a lot of
drugs and there was a lot of stuff going
on and kids were just vanishing you know
never see it again
which is true but as me didn't have the
internet back then you think at least
one person would have said hey you know
we're all going it was an area where
like that it was almost kind of like an
Appalachia style
area from what I remember that right
well it was outside of it was part of
Houston
no I meant Appalachia style
area like you said it was a pretty low
income area yeah and I think even a lot
of the the parents were kind of derelict
yeah not I mean the parent I don't know
about that I mean almost all the kids
were reported missing really like their
their parents were like looking for them
and spent a long time so I remember I'm
it was mostly just it was mostly just
the cops that were just like I they run
away you know you know how teenage boys
you always running away and then
subsequently getting raped and tortured
yeah just I kind of remember the basic
story and I remember what went down and
it just it boy it makes a bad image for
that for fraud it was outside Houston
uh-hmm
yeah it's hard to believe that happened
there although Dean Corll it should be
he wasn't originally from taxi was
actually from Fort Wayne Indiana
so yeah before we get into the main
topic of the show let's do a couple of
little shout outs first of all I want to
say shout out to Melanie who gave us a
very generous donation on PayPal so
thank you very much she does that every
now and again and it's always very much
appreciated thanks Baily and we also
have two new patrons one of whom is
named Dwayne and one of whom is named
Cody that's all hey you got yes thank
you very much we couldn't do the show
without all of you guys out there so
what else what other things do we have
to like mention about this oh but the
the improved audio of my book the unseen
hand is up now so with us yes so if you
purchase a audio copy of the unseen hand
should be the improved audio yeah it's a
better reading too yeah like I said some
people complained about the reading that
was a little too wooden yeah you did it
kind of like you do the show right yeah
well I mean you know I'm still reading
but I tried not to be so robotic I don't
think my older was robotic but you know
I have a reading voice and a talking
voice because when I'm reading I'm
reading on the page it's like you know
what I'm talking I'm just kind of like
but yeah so I think that's pretty much
all the shout outs we had maybe I guess
yeah you know just the usual stuff but
I'll save that till the end all right so
said we're talking about Dean Arnold
coral every time I say that I always
want to say like [ __ ] Rick on the
walking dead yeah but yes that's how it
makes me think oh so like I said he was
actually born in Fort Wayne Indiana um
not a huge amount known about his
childhood he had one of those family
dynamics where his father was like super
super strict and his mom was like super
protective they divorced a couple times
when he was growing up they divorced and
reconciled and then divorced again and
blah blah blah
so you know at some stage when Dean was
younger his mom had like moved out like
and they lived in a trailer park and
others have other kind of stuff now
interestingly when Dean was a kid I
didn't really see anything that said
that he did any kind of like serial
killer [ __ ] like you know kill little
animals or set fires or anything like
that
by all accounts I mean he was very quiet
he was a loner of that type of thing but
he seemed to be like a real sensitive
kid like he was you know seemed like
really nice really concerned for others
which is strange considering how he
ended up but there was that kind of
thing too now when he was seven-years it
was kind of he was a little bit sickly
as well when he was seven he got
rheumatoid fever and they told him not
to do like PE and stuff like that
because he was like a two-week so like I
said his parents had remarried and then
they moved to Pasadena then they got
divorced again the mom kept the sons but
then she remarried this she remarried
this traveling salesman named Jake West
now the two of them moved to this town
called I'm not sure how it's pronounced
but it's V door or vie door or something
like that it sounds like a [ __ ] door
maybe in billing I don't know it sounds
like a spiders name I think and they
started a small candy company just out
of their garage and it kind of grew like
into a thing which is which is how Dean
would end up later on being called the
Candyman so Cole starts working for the
candy company like after school and like
you know whatever on weekends or
whatever
now when he gets into his teenage years
again still very shy very much a loner
he was in the band he played trombone he
seemed to really like that but that was
kind of like you know all he was really
into he got good grades everyone said he
was well behaved like I said nothing
unusual really other than being kind of
quiet so at this point he graduates his
family moves to the heights this
particular neighborhood of Houston like
I said kind of a lower middle class area
you know I think like at the turn of the
century I was watching a documentary
about Dean Corll and they said that at
the turn of the century it was kind of
like you know the the fancy like
upper-class neighbor who the heights of
Houston and stuff like that but you know
as the decades went on and economic
depression and people moved elsewhere so
it you know it's kind of past its heyday
I guess you could say so they moved to
this particular neighborhood and they
opened the candy company like in its own
separate building it was called pecan
prince hmm which whatever okay yes so
Dean is working there and he would give
like free candy to the kids in the
neighborhood you know yeah um you said
pecan Prince right yeah as soon as you
said that man started thinking of this
uh probably I know Rawlings yeah yeah
went outside here they call that
pralines but they're not word is there
problems with that damn yeah and things
are good man we should make I can make
some it's just sugar and butter sugar
that makes everything yeah
fattening you puts it yeah pecans out
again that's why it's good damn yeah why
do you do this to me you're the one that
said it on me I just said those I'm just
telling you I've had him in a long time
driving down on the wax paper yeah
they're all you eat them and they're
kind of soft and then they break and
it's got that little bit of like sugary
grit to them yeah but you know only you
could only come up with some [ __ ] like
that the south just this makes me can
you have butter and sugar
Kahn's in it come on put some pecans in
it yeah well in the South we also have
chess pie which is pretty much just
sugar pie
yeah pretty much what it is yeah this is
all came this all comes from the same
people that would put peanuts in their
coca-cola yeah yeah I'll like I'll put
peanut but really fry so they didn't
take like a like so they fry up a banana
moon pie like that was something real
exotic as you know what's you can revoke
my southern cards I am southern gay guys
but I really do not like my eyes and I
specifically do not like anything that
is fake banana here yeah it's not Nana
Nana Nana Nana Nana Nana Nana boo Nana
moon yeah yeah yeah I don't like
anything I don't really like marshmallow
and stuff and I for real do not like any
artificial banana flavor I really like
Debbie snack cakes I looked at what the
last time we did then I remember what
I'm talking about yeah I probably but um
the last time I couldn't remember what
show it was on we were talking about
little Debbie's and I got curious and I
was like I saw I went to their website
to see like what once they still had and
it's like a lot of the ones I remember
growing up they don't really have him
anymore
do you know that they have ones white
people moved up in the world so you know
what they have memorized and I really
like super cakes and also those cake
rolls now they have one that's like a
combo of the both of those things it's
like a Swiss cake roll but it's like a
zebra cake on the outside I imagine
people in Australia don't know [ __ ]
we're talking about you just take a
bunch of sugar and a bunch of coin
what's that stuff corn syrup and corn
starch and make it make cakes out of
them they taste plasticky and really
sweety sweet but there's like certain
you would like away of them or you
deep-fry them and they're kids
well I say anything and exactly it's
just a lot of its nostalgia I think cuz
I you know when you're a kid and it's
like oh it's a big treat when you get
stuff like that you know so yeah I'm
gonna do that I'm that digression about
the because I'm sorry even brought in
pecans oh just thinking about pecans
little Montana problems so at this candy
store where Dean worked
they started um you know they're started
gonna rumors wrong because they have
like other employees and stuff like that
like other teenage boys that work there
and you know they're started to get
around like that Dean was making like
sexual advances towards some of these
other you know employees and he also
like you know cuz he was a bit older
than them at this stage he had put like
a pool table in the back of the candy
store like I said he would give kids
free candy so they would come over there
and hang out with now in 90 whatever
boys or girls boys yeah he did date a
girl at least one girl when he was in
high school or when he was a little bit
older and it was supposedly pretty
serious but it seemed like most of his
sexual interest was directed towards
boys even from you know from when he was
a teenager a little bit old did they
know did everybody know I don't really
know it just seems like most of the
stuff that I read around was just very
matter-of-fact it doesn't really say
whether anyone said anything about it I
think the way to dude turned out had a
lot to do with the way people treated
him for being gay that's kind of what I
suspect about well I suspect that about
Dahmer and like other killers like other
killers you know that we're getting that
we're not accepted for these guys all
came from a lot usually comes with some
kind of lower middle class background
and they're kind of like giraffes in a
sea of [ __ ] Buffalo you know I mean
they kind of stand out and they're
they're mistreated so what they do is
they hide it so they're always closeted
yeah and I think I think that closeted
causes some kind of a internal struggle
that trans that kind of trans morphs
into this feelings of you know kind of
like hatred so they become very sadistic
all these guys turn out to be sadistic
all these gays here
very sadistic it does seem like that too
you want to be Dahmer Dahmer was
actually not sadistic yet all that [ __ ]
post-mortem yeah but a lot of you know
John Wayne Gacy was very sadistic yeah
you know and this was this guy like the
family murderers from Australia that's
similar remember we did show on that
yeah because this guy did call he did
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] he did some like
really horrible like sexual torture yeah
like teenage boys and I think I do
really think that there's something to
do with that because you know when you
spend your entire look at anything I
think it happens to some straight serial
killers - and I'm not saying you know
I've said before on the show I think you
have to have something kind of [ __ ] up
in your head to start with like
genetically that I think you're born
with it you have a predisposition in
that direction anyway but then if you
have some kind of upbringing where you
are constantly being told that you know
the way you are is not right or there's
something wrong with you or something
like that where you can't just be the
way you are I think that [ __ ] some kids
up you know I'm clearly yeah you know
what though the cases we're talking
about it always struck me as if these
guys were telling themselves that they
were [ __ ] up yeah you know I mean it
always seemed like self guilt you know a
lot of times it seemed like the parent
that like the parents or the environment
that he came from that they didn't know
or they end make a big deal about it
it's just there's something about like
they were closeted themselves and I
think it caused some kind of weird well
because maybe they were even if their
parents didn't know maybe they were a
new date advantage it probably right
yeah they knew that they would be
rejected and well it's like [ __ ] them
up maybe they thought the rejection
would be even worse in their imagination
as it would be in real life yeah so they
you know so that mom get worse that's
what I'm thinking something like that
but yeah so in 1964 he gets drafted into
the Army this is for the Vietnam War
obviously he first goes to Fort Polk
Louisiana for basic training then he
went to Fort Benning and then he was
sent to where he was supposed to go for
his permanent assignment which
Fort Hood in Texas he was going to be a
radio repairman however he supposedly
really really really did not like
military service and I didn't realize
you could even do this for this reason
but he um went to them and set and
claimed hardship because he said that my
family needs me at the business you know
what I mean um because I think at this
point his stepfather had taken off like
his mom had gotten divorced again and
she had made Dean the vice president of
the candy company so he made the
argument well she needs me to help run
the business and the army said okay so
he only served for ten months and then
he was discharged this is 64 1964 yeah
well he wasn't really like a high
priority was just radio repair it's not
like yeah it's not like he was he wasn't
trying to dodge out of combat or
anything and he already and you'd
already been there for ten months I
think most guys only did a year yeah
maybe two yeah during in the conscripted
army so yeah they probably let it go
yeah and another thing is is that they
didn't really like him
they would let him go true yeah if he
wasn't if there wasn't really much to
him yeah and if he wasn't like they
thought he wasn't gonna be a team player
right but yeah he just you know he
wasn't contributing much you know yes
and people just didn't like to have him
around it'd be an easy way to get it rid
of him I should say to that even before
he went into the Army like I said he was
making like sexual advances towards
other kids that worked at the candy
store
now one kid actually like complained
about it but Dean's mom just fired the
kid yeah so she was like always kind of
having his back she friday Molina's yeah
she might not have she what I just
thought he was being a meanie and he was
like making it up or whatever trying to
get money or something so you know so
Dean gets out of the army he comes back
and he's working in the in the candy
business now at this stage he meets
David Brooks who would become one of his
accomplices later on but at this stage
he was only 12 years old he was in sixth
grade now like I said you know Dean
Corll is an adult at this point and he
is like let's see who's 1964 he was born
in 1930 and
so yeah he's like in his twenties and
he's hanging out with like 12 13 14 year
old boys yeah like I said that Michael
Jackson syndrome I guess so so yes so
he's like luring all these boys into the
thing hey come play pool and we have
free candy and all that kind of [ __ ]
right so yeah Neverland
yeah pretty bust in Michael Jackson's
chops though some people say he didn't
do that but we'll see I don't know yeah
it was awful suspicious yeah you know
it's like I'm not gonna take a stand one
where they're that oh man you have some
Ferris wheels and [ __ ] in your [ __ ]
house that's pretty weird statues of
Peter Pan everywhere it's very
suspicious
you know he's talked about how much he
likes children all these photographs of
Michael Jackson with all his children if
he likes children so much where the [ __ ]
of the girls these boys and those
photographs it's weird
it is weird yeah I mean yes there's a
very slim possibility that all could
have been completely innocent but it's a
very very every other situation like
that yeah catchy as [ __ ] yeah just
saying hilarious man that it could be
that rich and then have problems like
that even think you know he was in his
20s and he had that big old [ __ ]
palace with a train and all so you meant
by he might have been in his 30s
actually yeah I don't really know and
you think that you know if you had that
if you had a big ol spread like that and
you were a rock star you're gonna have
that thing just jam-packed full of women
all the time yeah now he's got a little
boys there yeah yeah you know you know
some shit's wrong yeah because that's
the thing it's like yeah you're some big
rich rock star it's like you either have
two naked women oh yeah naked men or
both yeah boys they fill me up with kids
yeah because he cares about the children
well where are the girls
it's justice would that be improper okay
that's some weird [ __ ] man
just gotta say I would say if I was him
in his position you know at that age and
everything Neverland Ranch would look it
would look like a cross between a circus
and a strip club a racetrack when I was
his age yet yeah all right so as I said
Jane coral is doing the same kind of
thing hanging out with a bunch of
teenagers even though he's in his 20s um
you know giving them candy giving him
marijuana they go and hang out at the
beach together
all this other kind of stuff now three
years later when David Brooks his little
12-yard friend is 15 years old David
Brooks drops out of school and he comes
over and like starts hanging out with
Dean Corll all the time that's because
he had ripened allegedly yeah because
Dean was like hey you can stay at my
place because at this point he had moved
into an apartment like over the candy
store and he lived up there by himself
so he's like well you know you can see
your whatever you want to you know so
allegedly a sexual relationship
developed between the 20 whatever a year
old Dean Corll and the 15 wait what year
was this again more or less what are we
talking about here mid-60s
I guess people just didn't really keep
an eye out for that kind of stuff back
then nowadays it was an innocent time
nowadays they had to call the law that's
what do you mean if you tried to pull
this crap nowadays like every single
neighborhood be calling the cops
yeah I know she would be on every Lane
it's [ __ ] sexual predator list on the
Internet your face would be all over the
[ __ ] yeah it was another time I know
that's what I mean it was the good old
days when all this horrible [ __ ] went on
but nobody knew about it like that was
so much better they acted like it did it
happen but I'm like cuz
no I know about this [ __ ] horrible [ __ ]
happen sometimes even worse [ __ ] that
happens nowadays it's just that nobody
knew about it or they didn't want to
think about it I don't know whether it
was considered an anomaly most people
behave themselves it was a freer time
and you think about it most people to
behave themselves but some people just
you know abused it yeah no [ __ ] dude
that's what I mean that's [ __ ] up I'm
an innocent time yeah all right so like
I said it and the [ __ ] up thing too is
that again allegedly um David Brooks
said that he that Dean Corll would give
him money to let him suck him off okay
you know what I mean yeah he that was
his thing like he would pay them because
later on when he had the accomplices he
would pay them to little plan to blow
you yeah that's some weird [ __ ] which I
always know it's real like I was thought
that was really weird I'm like you know
if I was a dude I'd be like well uh you
know I want to pay somebody to blow me I
don't want to pay to blow someone else I
was a you know the whatever floats your
boat I'm just saying well not this guy
but I'm not gonna attempt to see it from
that way
you're not gonna I'm not gonna tend to
see it that way no there's no way I'm so
let it be somebody's dudes gonna freak
and that's what they gonna do it just
seems like the wrong person is getting
paid in that transaction that's all I'm
saying for his silence whatever so yeah
so this kid is like hanging out and
they're kind of doing them whatever so
at this point
Dean's mom well the candy company I
guess failed or they closed it or
whatever so Dean's mom and his
half-sister they moved away they moved
to Colorado now they still I think his
mom like still kept in contact with him
and stuff but they didn't ever see each
other again after that time so after the
candy store closed and you know the free
candy train had you know left the
station there's no more free candy or
anything like that so Dean gets another
job as an electrician at the Houston
lighting and power company I wonder what
kind of candy
they made you know I bet you they made
some saltwater taffy
I haven't had salt water taffy never he
always the last time you had salt water
town was the time that I ordered you a
five-pound bag and you ate the whole
thing in like two days
I know y'all want to give you fast and
easy salt water time can't be it was
three days but it was a five was it a
five-pound bag
pound bag of salt whatever he was always
complaining because he couldn't find any
and finally when I'm one of them
old-timey candy stores on Amazon and I
wonder this big huge bag when you're
something like here now be quiet but
then he ate it like a kid yeah even the
black licorice butter and black licorice
and cherry and strawberry and yeah it
was it was actually pretty good apple
green apple I'm not a big taffy fan but
I thought I thought it was pretty damn
good I have no skin we had these bars
called Laffy Taffy they still make those
don't think about a foot in half long
and about a quarter-inch
excited like her but it would like
stretch out to about five or six feet
before break he's all about the fruity
candy and I'm all about the chocolate I
like it yeah pretty much
it's funny because it's the same thing
about ice cream flavors yeah like you
like he likes like fruity like sherbet
and stuff like that whereas I'm all
about chocolate nut coffee you know
stuff like that
I like crunchy ice cream it's got to
have like cookies you can tell we're fat
people this kid - this kid - this so
that's kind of like a little bit of
background on the guy now they think at
least what they know about they think
that he killed like I said at least 28
people between the years of 1970 and
1973 all of the victims were boys
between the ages of 13 and 20 years old
um again almost all of the victims were
abducted or lured from the same
neighborhood which I'm not entirely sure
how big the neighborhood of Houston
Heights is but you think that some red
flags would have gone up somewhere like
why are all these kids disappearing
cuz that's a lot of kids I'm just saying
so they think I mean he might have done
some on his own the ones that they know
about are because his accomplices were
involved and they were there when it
happened they either procured the kid or
they were there when it happened or he
had told them about it so because that's
that's the only reason they know about
it because like I said they they
wouldn't have known about it if one of
those accomplices hadn't killed it was
some weird [ __ ] he was fast later on he
was paying one of them to go out there
and and meet guys both of them ePaper
they both them and told him to bring
these guys here and he'd pay him
yeah two hundred dollars each yeah and
what he would do that's a lot of money
back then what he would do is he would
like take a guy and handcuff it put a
handcuff on one side and pull that
handcuffed to a hole in a board yeah
Bohr was about two feet wide and
probably out five feet tall
it was 3 feet by 7 feet by 7 I have a
picture of it yeah and he'd pull the
other end of that handcuff through there
and handcuff it to another guy so you'd
have two of them handcuffed yeah yeah
they're like with a board in between
them and then do bad [ __ ] to him yeah
and soon as it was horrible one of me
had two brothers in that position he
told me that after you tortured him he
told him that he'd let one of them go
with if one would kill the other and
they sat there beating each other trying
to kill each other I remember exactly
what happened he did um you know it's
creepy is he actually did two sets of
brothers he did one set of brothers at
the same time yeah and then one he
kidnapped one brother and killed him and
then a year later he kidnapped the other
brother yeah what he would do is why you
why he'd have these guys chained up to
this board he had a bunch these glass
rods yeah they were used some of the
beakers or something yeah they slip the
slip that down these kids urethra III it
and then take a pair of pliers and crush
make them yeah well I was inside there
yeah man how would that even occur to
you yes he also castrated some of the
victims I didn't know about that one he
would cut off their jet their you know
testicles or he would chew them off oh
did that a couple times
because when they found some of the
bodies sometimes their genitals were
separate in a separate little baggie say
I'm [ __ ] charming mmm [ __ ] damn I'm
sorry guys we always talk about such
cheerful [ __ ] time yeah this show
that's bumming me out kind of I'm trying
to think of what I would do to that dude
if I had him well you can't do anything
to him now because he's died alone yeah
okay
I'm just trying to imagine Matt trying
to how do you get even with somebody
like that that's what I mean and the
fucked-up thing is like even if you did
like the most horrible [ __ ] you can
still not quite even with him and he'd
probably enjoy it yeah I kind of had the
feeling he'd probably enjoy it you know
he seems like that type of guy probably
maybe like put him in and what they call
a mongolian death coffin can't really
lay down in it you can't stand up in it
you got a hole in there that maybe you
can put a hand through I mean it's in
the middle of them yeah and then yeah
they do these Dead Mongolia and leave
you in there they only take you out of
thing once a week and you're in there
crapping in that box and you can't
really look out the hall too well cuz
it's in the wrong place yeah yeah so
like I don't turn a hole in it but we're
gonna put it in this most Awkward place
so just write directly in the center
yeah so you get to like lean forward to
look out to the hole and you couldn't
get your hand out of it that you know
what that this gives me like an
existential type of sadness because it
seems like look at the waste of
imagination that somebody wasted all
their brainpower thinking of the worst
[ __ ] [ __ ] they could do to other
people instead of doing something
productive and useful well what are you
talking about some other deaf coffin are
you talking or just in general
torture things I think they put people
in mind goalie in death coffins because
you know in that in during that period
there was no such thing as a
penitentiary or a prison it was a they
were a kind of a nomadic tribe near the
mountain the Mongolians you know at the
Kazan they've had this [ __ ] for like a
thousand years so the first thing that
came to their mind but you'll just put
the dude in a box and then
put the Box in basically like a little
courtyard with a wall around it have
guys guarded yeah and that would be like
probably about the most effective
incarceration you could do in under
primitive conditions yeah I mean
kabillion up building a real
penitentiary or a prison it's quite an
undertaking yeah you need an industrial
society for that but you know these are
just wooden boxes you couldn't break out
of them they were thick you know cuz you
never if they we're gonna go to all that
trouble and this is a horrible thing to
say but if they're gonna go to all that
trouble why didn't they just take the
person just block him by the head and
kill him well some of them had certain
sentences you know they weren't gonna be
in there all that long some of them had
life though but the idea was to kill him
yeah and it's thing to die and you know
in horrible means now I say they were
made out of wood it was more like they
were made out of time I would that was
kind of like railroad ties you know
there's no way you could break them they
were thick I've seen him seen
photographs oh yeah yeah I don't know
why but that little conversation just
reminded me of like this [ __ ]
exchange that was on Mystery Science
Theater is this [ __ ] sci-fi movie and
the villain has this really convoluted
plan he's like I'm gonna take each of
the people that I want to kill and put
them each in a space capsule and I'm
gonna fire into the sign of all blah and
then crime is like would it be cheaper
and quicker to just bludgeon them right
here like yeah exactly
I don't know why they didn't do that but
that's what it doesn't mean that
everything thank you so yeah um let's
see so many of the victims were actually
friends or acquaintances of his two
accomplices because this other
accomplice was named Elmer Wayne Henley
who came along a little bit later a
couple of them had worked at the coral
candy company before it closed so his
kind of MO what he would do like I said
either he would do it or he would have
one of his accomplices do it like he
said he he paid $2,200 per head to his
accomplices to bring him people so they
would go out in his [ __ ] van like I
said this I don't know what this is
where this meme came from like the
[ __ ] white van with the blacked-out
because it did it had like the blue
curtains in the back windows and like
all the [ __ ] all of that [ __ ] so he's
going in his white Econoline van and
he's luring boys into the van by either
giving them candy or saying oh I'm
having a party I got pot I got Alka
all blah blah or I'll give him a ride
sometimes he would just like strong-arm
em off their bike if they were just
riding a bike down the street or
something like that it we're to the wise
umyou men out there if another man ever
comes up to you anywhere at any time
asking you won't go to a party to a
party you say no well not just man
anybody yeah if somebody you don't know
says have you guys seen the trailer for
that movie ha ha like that say finally
old chubby American women that's like
you know Oh buy some beer and she buys
the beers like hey want to come to a
party at my house yeah sure why not she
just looks like a harmless old lady
that's not how that's gonna do it's a
horror movie so you know I mean if
anybody you don't know ask you even if
people you do kind of know ask you to go
to a party just say no yeah I mean if
some dude comes with ya you won't go to
party who's gonna be there didn't mean
you hye-won do say that to me well kind
of Boston you're so sexy that he
couldn't like resist it yeah he just
sighed you like Sachin is like that
Street you know them going down the
street unless I get a piece of that I
was at a bar called The Rathskeller oh
you're kind of like this kind like a
punk rock bar okay this is dude came in
he goes hey man you a little party and I
was kind of drinking it I was like yeah
he was just me and you yeah he's serious
though yeah just just me and you oh [ __ ]
now it's harder party I'm good I'm good
it's a rape and murder party he's all
that a daddy you know yeah they are well
you know I thought I took it well I let
his laughter during I just laughed yeah
okay so like I said he would either lure
them into the van or he would just like
grab them off it off a bike or something
like that take him back to the house he
would usually then drug them or get them
really drunk while they were asleep he
would put handcuffs on them or he would
trick them into putting on handcuffs his
one of his accomplices would do that
sometimes he'd be like hey look at this
like magic trick that I can do and he
would put the handcuffs on and they go
look I can get out now you try and
you know then the other kid would put
the handcuffs on anybody like psych yes
so then they would strip all their
clothes off they would tie them to this
board or to Dean's bed and then they
would sexually assault torture them and
usually kill them by strangling them or
they would shoot them with a 22 caliber
pistol almost all of the victims were
killed with the same gun so then they
would take their bodies they would tie
them in they would put him in all these
plastic sheets and then he had like four
different dump sites now this guy like
moved around a lot which again should
have been like another red flag he would
move around like different apartments
and different houses like it well not
hear you that I know but I mean I'm
talking like he moved somewhere and then
like two or three weeks later he moved
somewhere else you know what I mean it
was a little weird his deposit I guess
that's why I kind of I'm like where's he
gonna lose [ __ ] money yeah two
hundred dollars per victim he has all
this money to like move like he said
what about [ __ ] Reynold upon I'm you
know I know it was the 70s but [ __ ] he
was just an electrician well they can
make good money right but you have to
get the jobs right I don't know no $200
per victim that's a lot of money
interesting better than me one yeah that
would have probably been close to like
five six hundred bucks right yeah I mean
you know I have a job too but I can't
afford to [ __ ] drop that I'd say hey
bring hey I'll pay you $200 to bring me
somebody to kill what the [ __ ] I can't
afford that [ __ ] what about the balls if
I wanted to balls it takes to talk a
fifty year old guy to go out there and
go bring you somebody to kill then you
tell him that ya did it well and they
were there for the later ones
yeah how the hell'd they get it you know
well it was friends of theirs yeah they
don't know what was gonna happen
yeah they must have been it was Tim he
got it he also knew what he was doing to
them some of this stuff was just like
really gruesome and they must have
either just been totally like cowed into
submission and terrified or something
there was there was more to it than that
they must he somehow held power over
mentally well Brooks for sure because I
think that he started as they would say
now
I think he started doing that I mean
because Brooks is only 12
David Brooks is only 12 when he met him
you know it somehow yeah twelve-year-old
boys are stupid you know I'm sorry well
you know 12 year old kids in general
stupid um but so some older guy is like
hanging out with you and you like feel
super cool because you're like hanging
out with this cool older guy that was in
the army then you see this dude rape
these guys these guys and then torture
him to death and kill him maybe he
thought that was cool I don't think he
did because I saw some interviews with
him and you know I don't want to get
ahead of the story because I never I saw
some interviews with the guy what was
his name again the diggity the kid who
shoots coral well one of them one of
them is David Brooks and one of them was
Penley Elmer Wayne Hema I think Handley
was one shot a guy that shot him yeah
supplement Handley he was a bit older I
think yeah and he he kind of had excuses
for the whole thing based on what I
remember said that the guy had kind of
had like power over his mind and kind of
brainwashed yeah into it and on that one
particular murder there was a girl
involved he told hee hee now it's the
last one he was in torture that girl he
said he couldn't stand it anymore so he
picked up the pistol yeah they struggled
over for a second he shot him in the
head and he let them all go yeah that's
yeah we'll get to that but that yeah
that's how it ended up and that's how he
ended up getting caught but I just just
thought his weary and him he's doing
life he's doing life a bizarre they're
doing a item for which I'm not sure that
would have happened and I don't had
coral still been alive and here's the
here's the thing I remember thinking
after the whole cases that was kind of
unjust cuz those guys were pretty young
when all that was going on they were
they were just teenager and they were
kind of victims of it too and they kind
of had their I think this guy had pretty
firm grip on him mentally yeah
they were scared of him you know well a
lot of times when you're not touching
your little kid you don't really know
the full extent of an adult's power yeah
and I mean because I think they were
afraid that if they hadn't gone to the
police that you know he could have
killed them somehow
yeah he probably lied you know fry live
- well honestly I think that if I'm
remembering correctly Elmer Wayne Henley
who was the guy that ended up shooting
him now I think that when he first came
to Dean corals house he came there like
as a victim like he was a potential
victim right but coral ended up liking
him enough and saying hey I'm gonna
recruit you into right you know push
around other kids for me yeah and then
he saw something in him yeah and there
was something about I think there was
something about how he used his guilt
against him to control him he felt
guilty about doing it once so then he
just made him do it again and again and
again again yeah right cuz like I said
you have to got him into it deep yeah
these were teenage kids right you know
and the guy again he wasn't much older
yeah I don't think I'd be given him life
yeah well like I said they both got that
but but I'm saying that had Dean Corll
not been killed like I'm not saying that
I'm not happy that he's [ __ ] dead cuz
good and good for Henley for [ __ ]
shooting and finally but you know had he
still been alive to answer for his
crimes I feel like the accomplices would
have got a lesser sentence because I
feel like they punish them so harshly
because the in coral wasn't allowed to
punish there's no it nowhere to punish
so I kind of feel like they were like
well we have to have justice served
somewhere so these two accomplices are
still here they've confessed to knowing
about this stuff and helping him to
procure victims so we're just gonna give
them the maximum sentence because Dean
is not here right to give it I didn't
really agree with that verdict I kind of
don't either it's like I'm not
exonerating down because you know they
they did it for a while but they were
too young
yeah they were just kids I don't really
I don't think they really understood the
full magnitude of what was happening
yeah we're scared they were easy there
easy manipulate kids that age yeah
that's what I did you know I mean I do
think they needed to be punished but I
don't think they should have been
incarcerated yeah there were about 18 or
19 and then since I'm wearing em therapy
and [ __ ] yeah they might have turned out
all right India never now but yeah so
like I said so
the bodies have almost all the victims
like I said the ones that they know
about have all been found I think
there's one or two that haven't actually
been identified but he had for dumping
grounds he had a boat shed that he
rented he had a beach like a place on
the beach of the boulevard Peninsula
where he would bury stuff there was um
there there was a lakeside there was a
log cabin on Lake Sam Rayburn which his
parents owned and he buried some bodies
on that property as well and then there
was another beach in Jefferson County
where he buried some other ones so you
know like I said they didn't know about
any of this until later on you know when
Henley came forward and told them he
knew where all the bodies were so yeah
now another [ __ ] up thing too is that
Dane would sometimes aside from all the
horrible [ __ ] like I said all the
genital mutilation and the rape and
torture and all the other stuff he would
sometimes make his victims write letters
or call their parents to tell them that
they were all right that they were
Runaways and yeah they were fine and
stuff like that so he would do that he
also tended to keep keepsakes from his
victims usually keys for whatever reason
he was kind of into that like I said he
kind of moved around a lot too which
didn't you know it didn't strike anybody
is weird at the time I guess because no
one was really thinking about it but
thinking about it now it seems kind of
weird but um I kind of wanted to get
into a little bit of like some of the
individual cases like you know the
individual murders and stuff like that
but I think we're gonna take a break
first just before it gets too late so we
can all right
you know refill it cuz you look like you
probably need to refill soon all right
but yeah so when we come back we will
talk some more about the victims of Dean
Corll the Candyman horrible horrible
serial killer who happily happily is
dead but we'll be back in just a few
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and conclude at the end
of the day at this house is very much
haunted and will continue to be on the
dome a long time
[Applause]
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century vol 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts by
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format alright we're back from
the break yeah we do like individual
cases on this right yeah I'm just kind
of going through some of the kind of
nasty details of what he did in these
boys during this tour we talked about
some of that already issue and dudes
nuts off and continue putting glass rods
up inside people and crushing them with
pliers and man was nasty yeah making one
kid beat another kid to death how would
you even like think of that like I said
yeah he said one of brothers is if you
kid if you if you guys start fighting
whoever kills the other I'll let you go
that's like some sauce and I don't think
they could I don't think I don't think
they ever I don't remember I don't
really remember the Jesus I think I
don't think they were ever able to kill
one another though their board was in
between them well I don't know I didn't
I didn't get it kill both of them but he
did yeah I don't think ever that one
like I said that was the only that
wasn't the only set of brothers he did
that to either he just did one at the
same time mm-hmm all right so his first
known victim was an 18 year old named
Geoffrey Conan and he was a college
freshman at the University of Texas
September of 1970 he was apparently
hitchhiking back to see his parents in
Houston they're presuming that Dean
picked him up while hitchhiking and then
took him back to the house and when they
found his body later on it was actually
David Brooks you know
in 1973 who actually love the know where
the body was it was at Highland Beach he
had been strangled
he was gagged he was found naked and
wrapped in plastic he had been raped you
know all that kind of stuff you know he
had his hands and feet bound also now
around the time that this happened like
I said now this is his first known
murder he might have done some by
himself before this I will talk about
that at the end but this is the first
one that they know about because Brooks
knew about it so what happened at this
point was that David Brooks comes to
Dean corals house and reportedly he
interrupts Dean Corll in the middle of
he had two teenage boys in there
strapped to the plywood torture board so
he comes in and he's like hey what's
going on or whatever and Dean says hey
if you don't tell anybody about this
I'll give you a car damn so david says
okay like you know he's 1516 years old
whatever
so Dean buys him a green Corvette damn
he's good to his word I get yeah he did
he actually he actually a bottom car now
apparently David Brooks did not see Dean
Corll killing these two but he said that
Dean told him later that he had killed
him and this was the he had killed him
and he said this is the point where he
said hey if you bring me boys I'll give
you $200 per head
at which point Dave it's like okay
sounds like a plan
my guess so he starts like bringing his
friends and stuff like that so the next
ones that they know about happened in
December of 1970 now these were two
fourteen year olds James glass and Danny
Yates they were at a religious rally in
near the Houston Heights neighborhood
they got lured to his apartment I think
this is actually the second time they'd
been there because I think Brooks had
like his said hey come hang out with my
friend Dean he's really cool or whatever
so they just said oh we're having a
party there whatever say you know
brought him back they both got raped
strangled and buried in the Boatshed six
weeks later there was another one
january 30th 1971 these are the two
teenage brothers donald and jerry
waldrop now they were walking to a
bowling alley
they were then enticed into Dean's van
and then driven to his other apartment
cuz he had moved subsequently since the
last murder I don't know if he like
moves after every murder because it
definitely seems like he might have been
nervous at that stage that's what I mean
he's he would only do like two or three
at one place and then he would like move
to another apartment and then do a
couple more and then moved to another
apartment it seemed like he was moving
like every six weeks or so might have
been kind of paranoid think that's what
I was thinking and maybe that might have
like helped him not get caught maybe
because like I said he didn't get caught
right when do you think about it he but
he did it for like three years that they
know of
he's probably imagining that the cops
are back there putting two and two
together
yeah which and if there may have been if
they were good cops they would have but
nobody did well maybe he thought there
were witnesses out there that knew that
he was that those kids were in his
company somehow yeah like I said it just
it seems like so many people drop the
ball may not be the situation at all may
have been the heating really like the
location where he was and you know he
had money and he was just able to move
around and you know just looking for a
good place that's might have been what
he was doing yeah yeah but yeah so these
two brothers were also raped strangled
and buried in the under the Boatshed now
between the months of March and May of
1971 they think that he killed three
more these were all from Houston Heights
David Hill agaist Malley Winkle those
two were kidnapped together in May of
1971 and were killed now interestingly
it was around this time because remember
I said Elmer Wayne Henley was the second
accomplice
but around this time this is when he was
brought to the apartment as a potential
victim right
but for some for whatever reason Dean
Corll was like hey I think you should be
my second accomplice you know what I
mean yeah so like he was originally
intending to kill him but he saw
something in him I guess that he thought
would make a better accomplice so he
gave him the same deal that he gave to
Brooks and Henley accepted it
yeah so that's how that whole thing went
down now in August of 1971 Dean and
David Brooks are walking around and they
see the 17 year old kid that David sort
of knows his name is Reuben Watson he
was walking home from the movies so
Brooks says hey why don't you come to
Dean's house for a party where I'm in a
big party later on so the kid said fine
and he also ended up strapped to the
board tortured and strangled also buried
in the Boatshed now there's some there's
some uncertainty too because Dean said
that he was a participant in a sexual
slavery ring so he said that he knew
other dudes in Dallas that were into the
same kind of [ __ ] and it's weird because
after he died and they like searched
through his stuff and everything they
found like photographs like you said and
some of the people in the photographs
like some of the people in the
photographs were people that they had
found their bodies and they identified
them they knew who they were but some of
the people they didn't know who they
were so they don't know if these were
other victims that were dead somewhere
or victims that he tortured and let go
or you know whatever but they said the
presence of these photographs kind of
maybe bolsters the theory a little bit
that he kind of knew other dudes in
Dallas maybe that we're into this kind
of thing but they're not really sure
because neither of his accomplices
you know David Brooks or Elmer Henley
knew they said well we never met anyone
else yeah i'ma call bullets you do with
anything or a slavery rarity [ __ ] on
it yeah well I don't know how true that
there's been several these serial
killers tell victims that they were
involved and they never liked that to
put that girl in a box mm-hmm talent you
know and they told her they were
you know that he had connections in this
big slaver it's a fantasy that they have
I think it's a story that they come up
with the kind of like
[Music]
it was a way of making his two little
go-getters what would anybody call him
his accomplices to make them think that
they were that he had like a higher
purpose behind him and that there was an
entire organization yeah
that way he could say well the people
from this organization will come and get
you that kind of that kind of [ __ ] that
might have been yeah that might have
been losing that important and part of
some big mafia yeah he was like telling
them yeah and then that's kind of you
could kind of say well what we're doing
is a little more normal than you think
it is this is happening every oh yeah
that's a good snack yeah like telling
video there's other people that yeah
they're say you just don't know there's
thousands of that's what yeah yeah I did
everybody likes it when I do voices
serial killer wait you don't know that
you know you don't know there's
thousands of us there probably are but
yeah oh [ __ ] are you gonna talk about
like how you're very upset and you have
sexual problems I'm sexual problems
somebody said that you should do that on
every show I got very upset horse the
reverb set you know of course but I told
them that you know I had sexual problems
and we're gonna work it out well I got
done I told them that you know I'd have
to strangle them and of course they were
very upset it's okay though that's
probably exactly that's what it sounded
like to me this guy also has sexual
problems yeah this dude here man he was
[ __ ] a lot more cruel than drader
though Jerry oh yeah Rader didn't good
take it this far yeah this is some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like I said this is this
is somebody sitting around imagining
it's like hey what if I took the little
bitty glass rod and stuck it up some of
these urethra and them yeah
wires well I think he also did it over a
longer period of time to him you think
he kept several of these kids alive for
I think a couple of days in some cases
wasn't it in some cases yes yeah usually
he would I think he would just bring the
back and rape or torture them for like
an hour or like a day or something you
didn't kill them but um maybe a couple
of them we kept a couple of days right
now I just kind of thinking he can't
this someone was like a couple of days
it might have been yeah okay so the next
one they think was somewhere around
February of March of 1972 they're not
entirely sure which one this one is this
one was another one when they lured him
to the house they said hey we've got pot
you know we're having a party or
whatever so the kid comes there they
think this might have been a kid called
Willard branch he was 17 year old he was
17 years old he was a friend of both the
accomplices so some friends those
[ __ ] dudes were yeah hey we know all
these kids take over this house get
[ __ ] murder
what the [ __ ] not only murder but
tortured raped right before they get
murdered
yes Christ so yeah but that but Willard
branch they did find that guy's body and
that seemed like about the time when he
had disappeared so they think that
that's who they were talking about the
next one happened in March of 1972 this
was an 18 year old named Frank Aguirre
he was walking home from work he works
at a restaurant and they call him over
to the van and they say hey you know we
got pot and beer and you know come and
hang out with us and stuff and like he
said he said yes but you should never do
but he did he kind of knew them so it's
not like they were complete strangers
that's the scary yeah so yeah he gets
over there and then Brooks I think
talked him into like he did the trick
where hey you look at the magic
handcuffs or whatever and I can get out
of him and now you try and then he put
the handcuffs on things like yes which
the handcuffs
yeah so basically and then they just
they [ __ ] raped and killed him also
[Music]
yes so this is I think this is the point
here where this was the first time
actually Henley saw him doing it this
Elmer Wayne Henley like David Brooks had
seen it before
but was keeping it to himself I think
Henley knew that it was happening but I
think this was like kind of around the
time that he first witnessed it but he
still stayed on board like I said you
know it might have been because he was
scared of the guy it might have been for
whatever other reasons he done I think
they were I think they thought that this
guy was in this big sex mafia of these
powerful yeah
Houston moon maybe they better listen to
him or they did killed and end up on the
other end of that damn board that's I
thought was going on it's what I think's
going cuz like I said I mean Henley was
actually first intended as a victim yeah
that's why he was brought there they
were gonna rape and kill him just like
yeah he had talked to me he had talked
himself up to the point where them kids
were scared of him and just amazing yeah
I think yeah yeah I don't doubt it
yeah so then there was another one in
April 1972 because these is so these are
happening like pretty close together
it's only like a month or six weeks like
in between um you know it wasn't a case
like I said like BTK where you know he
would go years and years about killing
one this was like pretty common because
all of these happen he killed at least
28 people within like a three year span
and he might have killed some people
before that too
it was a project yeah one of my projects
that's I guess guys project yeah a
little project varnas well planned ours
mine no I was careful thank you for
showing up yes so the next range think
about this case but these were boys
you're not supposed to do that that's
gay you know well you know I think the
funniest / saddest thing is about the
impression that you do did Dennis is
that even if he doesn't say that stuff
out loud I think that's what he's
thinking okay yeah guy's a pervert yeah
not like fine upstanding no I'm straight
I'm straight an unreal man you know
those [ __ ] have to deal with my
sexual problems I'm a real man you know
I measure some grass and collect some
dogs go back to the church take some
pictures maybe do a grave get down in it
some stockings on yeah it was ditched
Anki you know but it's not gay yeah so
yeah so the next one happened in April
1972 this was a 17 year old named Mark
Scott also a friend of the two
accomplices he was actually taken by
force he was not Lord and he like fought
like hell he even like trying to stab
them and [ __ ] like that but at this
stage so he's struggling and trying to
stab them and stuff now Henley points a
gun at him
like to get him to stop struggling at
which point marks just like [ __ ] it what
do whatever you want to do instead of
shooting me so he ended up raped
tortured killed just like the other to
make them [ __ ] kill you that's what
I'm saying it's like you know what I
mean I would rather just get shot in the
face any kinda maybe he didn't know what
was gonna happen well yeah I mean you
wouldn't guess you wouldn't know how far
we go right I mean I don't know it's
hard to say cuz I've never been in that
situation but Tara you if you chant or
try to dunk me and take me somewhere you
better kill me I'm not going anywhere
with anybody that's what we'll see
that's what I kind of made him like
u-turn see I'm like if this is not
nothing I'm not going anywhere if
they're gonna take you somewhere I'm
gonna assume the worst that's what I
mean kill me yeah all right so let's see
what was the next one so again he moves
again in June of 1972 I think this is
and then there were two
more kids that they abducted at the same
time a Billy Balch and Johnny Delon they
were actually tied to Dean Carl's bed
and Henley actually strangled one of
them so he did like Mert he wasn't just
watching he was like doing some [ __ ] too
and he also shot the other one in the
forehead yeah and then I don't think he
killed him though because he would then
he was strangled too
so thing the situation like that that
you have - what's his name probably told
him to do that if you didn't do it then
either being dead I'm just that's what I
mean I think you know I think it really
is like a gray area yeah because like I
said you have to think yeah they went
along with it and stuff like that but
you have to think these kids were what
like 16 17 years old and one of them was
12 when they met the [ __ ] guy yeah
and he'd been like hanging out with him
all this time and having sex with him
all this time
so you know how it is yeah don't trust
gays that's what Charles everybody would
say probably don't trust gays yeah yeah
cuz straight guys like Emerson yeah like
we should trust them instead yeah all
right so then the next one I think was
19 his name was Billy writing her now
this guy interestingly at least
according to David Brooks um he was
actually raped and tortured but at this
point Brooks said that he was able to
persuade Dean to let this guy go so and
I don't think he was one of the bodies
that they found hmm
so there's one I'm not that was let go I
guess so according to one of the
accomplices I don't use it because like
I said this all comes from the
accomplices because Dean is dead right
yeah you know what I mean so after he
moved to this new address they think
that he killed about four more people
Steven Steven sickman was one of them
there were two more boys from Houston
Heights
that was in October of that year and
then there was a 19 year old kid named
Richard Kepner and that was in November
so between February and November of 1972
there were nine teenagers murdered five
of them were buried at Highland Beach
four were in the Boatshed now January of
1973 Dean moves yet again so he had only
been there a couple of weeks before he
killed another one seventeen-year-old
kid named Joseph miles then he left that
apartment and moved again to the address
where he would eventually be killed
which is the very famous 2020 Lamar
Drive in Pasadena Texas that was March
7th now interestingly between February
and June of 1973 they don't think he
killed anyone which is a very long
period of time for him because as I said
like a lot of these murders were very
very close together it was only like a
few weeks or a month in between now they
think what might have accounted for some
of this fallow time period was the fact
that he had I guess they looked at his
medical records or something he had
something called a hydrocele hydrocele
what I didn't know what that was is that
so I looked it up yes don't Google it
I'm at a green blue unit close it's
actually in your testicle okay it's kind
of like yeah it's like a scrotal
swelling whoa yeah the weird thing about
it it's like I looked it up they said
it's actually really common you know
it's not life-threatening or anything
like that it's real common in like
newborns you know babies but they said
it can happen in like boys or older men
like if there's some kind of like
infection in their scrotum
see he wore an injury in their skirt he
didn't want to appear before the victim
in an imperfect form see um he wanted to
be look at what he wanted to look good
during all this yeah thank you good
eyeball all swelled up or whatever I
don't know what it looks like I didn't
Google pictures where's it man I don't
want to see pictures of somebody's fool
I can be
can't be raping others boy [ __ ] with
his balls like this that's probably
exactly what it wouldn't kill and he
didn't kill anybody all that yeah like
almost six months
Nancy mom which is like unprecedented
but they think maybe that might might
have been why because he had like some
like scrotal swelling which I guess was
embarrassing for him so yeah isn't that
like I said I did I didn't Google
pictures of it I don't want to see
pictures of that [ __ ] I just looked at
the Wikipedia to cure himself that never
were to stop me never work right Dennis
yeah I'm a real man
[Laughter]
do you think the Dennis Rader's can like
watch this show in prison they let him
watch you they might they might have now
might let me might let them have cell
phones and tablets now I'm not sure I
don't know I think it depends on like if
you can have privilege in it I don't
think I don't I don't think he has [ __ ]
I don't think they they better not don't
him watching YouTube I Do's locked up
yeah he's like sitting there watching
television in a big day room feeling
full of dudes and orange suits and [ __ ]
orange jumpsuits yeah
without the air conditioning he'd better
not
yeah where's this guy keeps talking
about me name's Tom does impression it
doesn't sound like me it's very
insulting yeah I'm very upset all they
would have to do is write me I will come
on their show any time Tom what they
call an [ __ ] right I'm Jenny yeah
yeah I'm teach drunken dude is yeah so
you're pretty good jobs I think it's
getting worse
do you think that sounded like it no I
think I'm not gonna channel D C out I
can't impersonate Dennis I have to
channel Dennis called channel oh you
know don't channel them too hard because
I don't want to be like I start shaving
my head back then had like a big faux
like he hasn't [ __ ] my big five head
yeah yeah this is this is getting into
like some [ __ ] weird area channeling
channel yeah don't do a paranormal
special challenge channeling yeah Dennis
I'm okay as a guest I'm gonna do it
across from across the room yeah alright
so after after the ball swelling
incident okay
I'm just you know I'm just telling you
like I didn't wanna do I'm not putting a
sugar I'm just he was embarrassed he
hadn't appear had them appear before
those boys in his like 1% you know shorn
testicle shiny you know form he didn't
mind he's swelling yeah yeah he'd be
pretty like he'd like to be smooth like
a Greeks dead right so balls the same
size yeah yeah I don't even like I said
I don't even know how noticeable it is
I'm not God I don't know man but you
know and like I said if you're just if
he's like just rape because he would I
guess is horrible but he would he would
like tie them to the boards like you
know like on their stomachs and stuff
like that so it's like they're not
[ __ ] looking back there I'll be
[ __ ] who's looking back there you're
getting raped and tortured you know look
at anyone's balls [ __ ] this dudes
probably in his in his mind he's center
stage and all eyes are on him yeah great
for former yeah
I'm not that he's the main attraction
it's just funny to him that that would
even occur to somebody it's like yeah
people were like terrified and like
fighting for their lives are really
looking at your [ __ ] school yes come
on now
maybe it hurt he couldn't be banging on
that heart I guess whatever but yeah so
after that whole thing he was out of
commission for a long time evidently so
after it kind of got better in June I
guess then he starts like making up for
lost time right so you know his Wayne
Henley said later that he that he had
gone offline like a blood lust like
after that happened because he'd had to
go so long without um so he killed
between us so in the month between like
the beginning of June and the beginning
of July of 1973 he killed three more
people now at this point July of 1973
after these three murders David Brooks
he was he had a girlfriend who was
pregnant and they got married and so
Henley like kind of her Brooks kind of
like took off for a while to spend time
with his new wife and baby I guess and
so Henley was like now he's the only one
going out and getting victims so after
he was just doing it then there were
three more between July 19th and July
25th so kill him again yeah this like it
I mean there's there's not much gap in
between and he isn't a suspect at all no
the cognitive would even know anything
until I family hadn't shot his stupid
ass same weren't even really looking no
one was even no one was even saying oh
there's a serial killer nothing nothing
that's police dereliction that's what
I'm seeing yeah because the whole time
it's like a lot of these are parents
were and their parents were reporting
yes business a lot of these boys were
reported missing and then like I said it
was often like the same neighborhood
like the same area
no one said boo it's like eff some cop
was in charge me as a guys kids as you
get to smoking all that pot in there
right yeah they just said oh it they're
just a bunch of way of running down San
Francisco hang out with them what they
call them the Beatles
The Beatles yes that sounds like
something like a stupid old cop yeah
that's the thing back then but yes that
that's what kills me about this is that
this was going on for years all the kids
were disappearing from pretty much the
same area yeah and cops were just like
Matt they're all just running away who
can teach it wasn't the cops son with a
s as one it was you had a know you had a
cop that had been promoted above his
station you know I mean yeah running
that local area and he made a decision
now that that's [ __ ] don't look for
them yeah just move into another area
well yeah but all I can promise like
some higher up that was just like oh we
don't we don't [ __ ] that's
missing-persons they're running away we
just want to sit around like [ __ ]
drinking coffee and not doing well you
can look at it this way they didn't have
a body yeah there's a lot of missing
people a lot of people move yeah you
know this move away and I guess these
are teenage boys in the early 70s yeah
the city there's everything are there
smoking pot and they're running away
yeah have you found a bomb had they
found a body maybe they live oh wait a
minute maybe they're not running away
yeah been something like that well and
like I said when I get to the whole
thing about you know Dean get killed and
stuff like that yeah they didn't believe
the [ __ ] kid it first to when he came
and told what was gonna yeah Serena so
August of 1973 Dean killed what is
thought to be his last victim which was
a kid named James Ramallah who was only
13 years old he was not Lord he was just
riding his bike down the street in
Pasadena Texas and was grabbed off his
bike and put in the van and he was raped
strangled and tortured and buried in the
Boatshed now a few days after this only
four days after this as a matter of fact
August 7th 1973 so and Elmer Wayne
Henley is there he was 17 at the time he
has this he invites this other kid to
Dean's house
the kid was named Timothy Curley so he
invites him to the party
now David Brooks was not there at this
party I guess he was still off with his
girlfriend or whatever but the two other
kids you know they go to the house
they're like huffing paint
whatever it is they're doing and drinkin
whatever they go on to get sandwiches
then they go back to Henley's house now
he knows this girl who's 15 her name is
Rhonda Williams now Rhonda comes out and
her dad is abusive and she's like you
know I don't really want to um you know
he's been beating up on me I don't
really want to stay in the house tonight
so Henley says to her well why don't you
come and stay at my friend Dean's house
you know it'll be fine you know you know
you don't need to be at your house or
whatever he didn't think Dean was gonna
go kill her yeah that's like I said
these are yeah yeah okay I'm not the
brightest kids so they take um so the
two kids and Rhonda go to Dean's house
at about they get there about 3:00 in
the morning
now Dean is absolutely livid that Henley
has brought a girl and he says Susie
Hickey girls yeah well reportedly he
said you ruined everything
hmm right so Henley like tries to chill
him out no man it's fine it's like you
know her dad was beating her up but she
needed someplace to go it's like I know
rose to take her blah blah so then Dean
seems to like calm down he's like okay
fine we'll ever you know have some beer
have some pot whatever they begin
smoking pot and drinking and everything
and Dean's just like watching them so
after a while the three kid the three
teenagers they all like drink a lot they
all like fall asleep or pass out or
whatever then Weatherall passed out Dean
puts handcuffs on all of him unlike
handcuffs them all together like ties
them all together so then do you want no
girls around them okay
we can't knocked the dad knocks the
camera over okay what are you doing back
there came on you
she's like saying she wants me she wants
to be on the show to watch your come in
front of the camera instead of behind
and knocking [ __ ] over all the time damn
what are you doing he doesn't trying to
figure it out okay oh you know yes yeah
when it fell it knock that down
thank you why you moving out and remove
it she jumped yes if she throws her
little butt all right so like so they
wake up they're all tied up and to be
with jealous of this girl well yeah well
he was like yeah you [ __ ] up this
whole thing you brought this [ __ ] 15
year old girl here yeah yeah so he says
hello you [ __ ] you bring your girls
right here test
so he says stealing the limelight away
from Dean Dean you know Dean thinks he's
sexy [ __ ] probably yeah I think
he's the sex move he thinks all these
boys love him job it probably sounds
like bringing them girls around here
yeah yeah so he says like when they wake
up he's like okay well now I'm gonna I'm
gonna rape and torture Tim Curley the 19
year old and then I'm gonna kill all
y'all so then he starts kicking the girl
in the chest
then he takes Henley who is his
accomplice he puts him he drags him in
the kitchen he like points a gun at him
and he says I'm gonna shoot you blah
blah blah henley says no no man you go
and do what you're gonna do to Tim like
you rape into him and I'll do the same
to Ronda just to show you that
everything's cool right right so that's
what he said
because he thought that Dean was gonna
shoot him you know so Dean says okay
that's what we're gonna do then that's
the plan so he unties Henley then he
takes Tim and Rhonda into the bedroom he
ties them on opposite ends of the
torture board then heated then he gives
Henley a knife and he says you know cut
Rhonda's clothes off and it's like I'm
gonna go over here and rape and kill the
guy and you go over there and rape and
kill the girl so at that point you know
Henley's doing as he's told he cuts all
our clothes off and everything like that
Tim starts like freaking out and yelling
and everything now Rhonda looks at Wayne
Henley and says is this for real like is
this really happening and he says yeah
it is and then she says to him are you
going to do anything about it hmm
and I guess that kind of maybe snapped
out of it because then Wayne says okay
well can I take Rhonda in the other room
like we need some privacy or something
like that and then Dean doesn't say
anything to him
so then Wayne picks up Dean's gun and
points it at him reportedly says you've
gone far enough
and then Dean just starts walking I'm
like yeah shoot me you're not gonna do
it except he did BAM right in the
[ __ ] forehead so he shot him in the
forehead he shot him two more times in
the shoulder he starts lying on the wall
and then he shot him like three more
times in the back just for the pistol
with an arm he was just laying around
well he was he was busy with with the
kid okay like raping the kid he's just
had the gun there like by the side so
you know yeah so Wayne just like picked
it up and [ __ ] shot him with it so
then he's like so the three teenagers he
they get them all untied and everything
like that they put their clothes back I
go like okay [ __ ] now what are we gonna
do I had a run out of said nothing well
yeah I think Tim said yeah we're not
gonna say anything like [ __ ] it but
Wayne actually said no we need to call
the police so they as far as I know they
stole the 9-1-1 call and he called and
he said he calls it like 8:30 in the
morning on August 8th they were to jail
over then I would have just left yeah
and he says quote unquote y'all better
come here right now I just killed a man
now when when the cops got there he
tried to explain like what had been
going on he's like look this guy he
didn't probably didn't say he's a serial
killer but he said he's killed all these
people you know self-defense blah blah
blah now the cops did not believe him at
first because like I said at this point
they were just like oh these boys run
away they didn't like know anything
about it but Henley said three names
that the police were like hey those were
missing-persons cases that were on file
like with the Houston Police Department
so maybe there's something to this story
right like I said they didn't believe in
my first until he came up with those
three names um now Henley like he was
perfectly willing to like it she said I
don't care he knows I'm like sick of
this whole thing um you know
you know also he's willing to go to jail
so he was willing to like he just didn't
he couldn't take it anymore like I said
he's 17 year olds he's 17 years old now
he's the one that kind of came he came
forward and said pretty much like
everything that happened now Henley
hadn't been in it since the beginning
Brooks had Brooks came in later with his
dad and turned himself in like the other
accomplice yeah so between the two of
them they pretty much told the cops
everything about what had been going on
for the past three years they knew where
almost all the bodies were and they took
the cop they went with the cops like to
all did though like look we'll prove it
to you there's this Boatshed there's
this thing on the beach there's a song
says stuff they knew all the places and
cops went there and found pretty much
all the bodies so they knew that they
weren't bullshitting now the [ __ ] up
thing is that they ended up finding I
think 27 bodies but after they found 27
bodies and like I said they identified
most of them I think there are two or
three that are still not identified but
after they found the 27 bodies they
stopped looking and I always wondered if
it was because I know this is a [ __ ]
up thing to say but prior to Dean corals
body count the highest body count was 25
you know the serial killer before that I
think his name was like one Coronas and
they liked that one corona from
california so he had had 25 murders so I
think like once they like broke the
record they were they're like well we
found 27 bodies let's wrap this up he's
already killed more people than then the
best-known like the highest body count
serial killer there may be bit more well
they know that there were for sure at
least one or two more yeah because a
couple of them that that Henley and
Brooks knew that had been killed their
bodies were still like on the beach and
they were found like later they were
found like in the 80s like by different
people you know one just got stumbled
across and stuff like that but had they
kept looking in the 70s back then they
probably would have found them I
remember one
remember one group of them was buried
underneath the storage shed it was a
boat shed boat shares everyone okay and
they said shed it was a lake cabinet it
was a couple Beach location yes and it
wasn't very big you know I mean it was
me by 10 foot by 15 feet or something
and they said there was what like 15 20
of them all buried right there
underneath that same boat shed some of
them like two or three thick yeah they
were three bodies thick yeah it was like
I said it was four different sites and
they were and some people were like how
the hell could nobody know about this
because that's what kills me said that
you know that all the ground was oily
with residue from these damn bodies I
mean burning the same spot this rotten
yeah there's like once I was like nine
of them there's like [ __ ] twelve of
them there's like there was everywhere
in a small area so concentrated
they said the earth was like black and
oily in and that you know whoever owned
whoever owned that boathouse should have
known something was up
yeah I mean it was well I think it was
rented to Dean Corll I think he rented
it and the lake house where a bunch of
bodies were buried that was his parents
lake house yeah now the beach there were
like two Beach locations I'm like was
that a private beach or a public beach
cuz it was a public beach there was a
bunch about these buried there you think
somebody would have come across I mean
later on somebody did come across one
like that like in 1983 or something like
that they found one of the ones of the
known victims they just hadn't found the
body but yeah it's a it's [ __ ] up and
a couple of the victims that they are
pretty sure that he killed because the
guy's missing and you know the
accomplices remember him killing them a
couple of them they've haven't found
their bodies now interestingly enough
like I said those are just the ones that
happened like that the accomplices were
there and that they saw or that they
heard about but prior to 1970 there is
speculation that he might have killed
however many people on his own because
some people who worked at the candy
place
it's like when it was still open back in
the you know mid to late 60s they said
that you know Dean would dig around a
lot behind the thing behind the company
like into the building and he always
said oh I'm I'm burying like this candy
that's gone bad like to keep insects
from getting in yeah sounds fishy which
like I said that sounds like a mix
monkey explanation it makes more sense
that all this stuff with these
accomplices and [ __ ] that he'd worked up
to this that's what I'm thinking he
might have had a solo career as you yeah
where he gained his confidence right and
really he's become overconfident when he
starts including accomplices and you
know paying guys to bring him other guys
that's some ballsy [ __ ] that's very
risky yeah you know well obviously any
whatever somebody because one good cuz
he [ __ ] shot him Jimmy I mean he
couldn't take it anymore I mean and good
for him that the shitty thing is that
like and like we were saying before both
those guys both got you know life
sentences and I think that that probably
wouldn't have happened if Dean Corll was
still alive to be punished
because yeah I'm not saying they were me
culpable but wives of serial killers and
the wives that had committed homicides
actually have gotten off before with
just a few years yeah yeah I mean really
they weren't even minors yeah so I don't
really get Burdick I don't mean with the
oldest one was what 18 and somebody well
he was 17 the older one was 17 when he
shot Dean okay so the oldest one
involved was 17 that's still a minor now
he didn't get he didn't get convicted
for the murder of Dean Corll because
they said that was self-defense
it was not yeah but it was all this
thing you got yeah he got in trouble
first but I always agree with it man cuz
I think he was under the under the
influence of a monster I think he's
scared to death of that guy have you
asked me yeah well you're probably gonna
that dude was involved in a big old
mafia of sex traffickers yeah you know
and that he probably thought he had to
go along with this yeah yeah I kind of
got money if he went along if he didn't
go along that he'd end up dead
yes probably much like it would she
probably wouldn't would have probably
you know it's had he gone to the cops he
probably wouldn't you know he'd have
been alright
just that he wasn't for some reason
wasn't thinking clearly I mean he's 17
although the thing is if I told that one
of then the cops are in on this - well
yeah but if he'd gone to the cops what
if the cops didn't believe him right
because even after he shot Dean even
after Henley shot Dean the cops didn't
believe him until he came up with the -
the missing and they went and looked and
found a 17 year old isn't thinking
clearly anyway true even a sane one I
think I think these guys are kind of
driven insane with the [ __ ] that they
saw ya mean whirly he worked him into
that yeah cuz it was several years yeah
but as I said I I kind of I'm kind of of
the opinion that Dean Corll probably
killed some people you know killed some
boys before he even got these
accomplices in on it like before 1970
but guys like I said when he was still
working at the candy company they were
like yeah he used to bury all this
spoiled candy quote-unquote and then
later on he cemented the floor over and
you know he was always doing everything
I don't think they ever checked yeah you
know and he was always digging around
and this like you know waste ground
there's over by a car park it's like he
had these big rolls of plastic sheeting
just like the roles that he had we're on
ya which seems a little very ambitious
in light of later events you know so so
there's no way of knowing they know that
he killed 28 is at least 20 but they're
like it's probably primary in the
thirties siddur ibly more than that as I
said you know when he was killed that
was like the highest body count I think
he's been surpassed so far didn't the
Green River Killer killed for though
that didn't he I think so but um at the
time like he said he beat the record I
guess which is a [ __ ] up you know
that's a [ __ ] up metric but yeah he
beat the record of walk by I think his
name was Juan Corona read that count
that California in serial killer I think
20 he had killed 25 people so as I said
when they were looking through all of
his [ __ ] like after he died they found
like all these pornographic photos there
were 16 different individuals in these
photos 11 of them were bodies that they
had found so they knew that those were
the victims was taking foreign pictures
up yeah but
just weird because the accomplices said
they didn't remember him like
photographing or filming any of them
what were they dead or alive and he's
taking pictures him alive okay so yeah
so he must have been doing some [ __ ]
like when they I don't know but the
other five they never found out who they
were as far as I know however they still
have not linked him to any maybe he just
killed everybody
well he did let I think for sure he did
let that one kid go at least according
to the accomplices he said that he had
like talked him into letting that one
gonna go but yeah so I don't know if he
was like involved in a bigger ring or if
he just said that like to keep people in
line like I said there were the fact
that there were five of these kids and
pictures that they don't know who they
were like they don't correspond to any
of his known victims or any of the
bodies that they found you know that
could that could mean that those were
other people that he killed those were
people those were kids that he was
trading pictures with other dudes I
don't really know you know he was alone
yeah I kind of suspect that too but yeah
those were kids those those were people
that he killed solo yeah or maybe some
of them he let go and there was that one
it's really disturbing of a kid that six
or seven year old kid tied to that board
but a tool box next to him never did
identify the dead little kid was yeah
he's just looking up trying to pull he's
pulling on his wrist to get freed he's
looking up at the camera it's weird it's
[ __ ] yeah that's like [ __ ] messed
up but yeah so I mean this whole [ __ ]
case is my stuff I mean I'm I'm
interested in this one and like I said
it's it's interesting to me because he
killed so many people yet he's not like
a household name and I think we've
talked about this before I'm kind of
curious as to why certain serial killers
somehow catch on like with the public
you know they didn't necessarily kill
more people than he was dead by the time
the early seventies rolled around and
the serial killer thing wasn't culture
alized I think at that time so he might
have been a little late yeah
and it wasn't this a sensationalist like
Ed Gein maybe yeah I mean it's still
pretty horrible yeah I mean it's maybe
because it was all like homosexual stuff
that yeah maybe people underneath the
radio win underneath the radar for
summary it's like I said I think I kind
of thought that when we were talking
about the family murders from Australia
I think that kind of happened there too
because the female the victims weren't
female maybe that's what if the victims
were female maybe it's maybe it's more
sensational for the for the media you
know I mean people pick people pay more
attention to because they're just
teenage boys a half like them boys yeah
cuz people they do always give oh hey a
little pretty white girl got killed
yeah you know and it's like all over the
[ __ ] news so a lot of it like a
little boy or somebody have another race
gets killed they don't give a [ __ ]
yeah well sad but a lot of it well it's
a product that they're marketing through
demographics pretty much yeah that's
what TV worked and well they figured
that's who was watching it right was
middle-class suburban white handball
yeah and then like what could be your
daughter and if I remember correctly
from the photos of the boys the boys
were basically kind of like teenage
pothead kind of kids yeah so they
weren't like you know it's not like
you're doing this to [ __ ] you know
Wally cleaver you know I'm talking about
this yeah yeah these were cleaver yeah
these weren't these weren't like the you
know the nobody call them these weren't
the yuppies you know yeah they weren't
the normal middle-class kids they were
kind like hippie looking typist well as
they were a little with lower
socioeconomic status and had long hair
care less about that when their lives I
think look like you know a member of
Black Sabbath or something a lot of them
so for some reason they just said well
these kids aren't marketable there
nobody's gonna really be all that
sympathetic to me because this doesn't
strike at the heart of Middle America
these are you know these aren't regular
kids these are kind of the you know yeah
poppy they were asking for it you know
we're gonna say like that's it
well no it's true because like some of
them would feel
well if you hadn't liked going up to
some stranger's van and smoking pot
going over his house smoking pot that
wouldn't happen to you it's the same
kind of thing that like [ __ ] girls
gay well if you're worried at that party
like drinking and wearing that short
skirt you wouldn't get rich then there
might have been that quick to blaming
their mud yeah there might have been
kind of that element well those kids
must have been gay there might have been
something like that they were gay yeah
we don't worry about them well that was
another reason I wanted to do this show
because I do feel like I don't know like
I do feel like these kind of crimes and
that's why I want to do the family
murder see because they kind of don't
get the same [ __ ] publicity yeah just
because I mean look at the [ __ ]
publicity Ted Bundy guy cuz he killed
pretty white girls like pretty college
men tell you that time I think probably
this it was it well if that guy was
raping those boys those boys must have
been gay I think that would might have
been which is really [ __ ] up that yeah
it must been gay trading sex for drugs
and that's how that went down so they
probably rationalized it that way yeah
yeah I got what was coming to them you
know right now supposed to be gay you
know yeah well you know gay people you
know they do that dance writer [ __ ]
dead guys ready to jump it in he's with
his team says well they've gone to
church we have a good program at our
church we can pray the game yeah well
pray the gay away all even I'm charged
with that program I bet yours I've
straightened out three gay men in my
time they're all married now man that
[ __ ] dad is rated I don't have to
imagine it I could have met well you
know I can imagine that's probably
exactly he would see he would do some
[ __ ] like that okay he seems exactly
like the type of person that would run
that type of program yeah after he
taking pictures of that dead woman in
the church yeah number having you did it
for no yeah you drag but yeah take
pictures ever on Church computer and
goes oh we gotta put this way because
wrong god I gotta help Marty become
straight are you come on here max we got
a prey animal prey
or let me clean this blood off the wall
and [ __ ] this dude yeah we talking
about like the [ __ ] worse if you made
it man it makes me feel so normal
because I just like I can't [ __ ]
fathom it like I find it fascinating but
I just at the same time I decide well
I've got problems
I've got sexual problems this is Ben
Dennis Rader on the 13 o'clock podcaster
yeah giving us some some insight into
the mind of the serial killer and how
they have sexual problems and how they
get very upset and don't be gay yeah yes
Rader want you to take away from this
entire if understandable gay people are
not with the Lord doesn't approve of
that bonding torturing and killing
that's a different thing in your army
technically technically I know it's a
sin Dennis was gonna say something but
is gonna say so he's gone yeah he's gone
we're gonna have to have a say you can't
dance and like channel living people
ganyan mm-hmm
when they're in prison they can oh it's
okay yeah it's a guys implant I wasn't
sure what the rule was because they're
like kinda like told the Living Dead or
The Walking Dead they're not really like
living a normal life they're just like
institutionalized
okay so part of their soul is free for
access like a channel it okay yeah I
wasn't sure how that works but thanks
for clear that I pulled it out of my ass
right now make me suspect Tom Tom
pulling things out of your ass you're
gay aren't you no gay is putting things
in
well to get them out you had to put them
in AI was noise the dog catcher drunk
[ __ ] talk about talking and Dennis
Rader's voice what to learn rapper
softly yeah I mean you could spend some
time together
ah well wait are you gonna be you or you
I don't
that does not sound like a good time
that's how I spend my Friday night I
don't wanna you know it is Friday night
you know everybody's got problems are
you gonna go you might get upset I'm
never selling you right now all right
all right so we're wrapping up this show
about the revolting Dean Corll who is
thankfully dead [ __ ] him yeah yeah
pretty much
you too Dennis yeah like you're so much
better it's alright
so that'll do it for episode 138
remember if you like the show like share
subscribe and all your social media
share with all your friends family
acquaintances even people you hate
that's pretty awesome too
if you would like to financially support
the show it would be greatly appreciated
and go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
I'm talking to the audience okay this is
not an advertising advertising based
program this is all about patrons
behooves you to give money to Tom and
Danny if you like the show you like to
show you if you like the show and you
you have patreon and you can send money
to patreon and I would spend I would
send money to patreon but I'm locked up
so if you want to hear more about
paranormal stuff and I'm not really too
big into paranormal stuff but if you
want to hear paranormal stuff and you
want to hear you know unsolved mysteries
and you want to hear about you know
people that have several problems
she wants a show to continue I I
recommend I would recommend that you
would send some money on patreon or or
PayPal yeah PayPal it'd be good idea
if you don't like patreon yeah because
we're not talking about government
checks here you know I work for the
government
that's where my authority came from but
things have changed today
the economy is different we've got a
different president now that I've been
locked up and what you need to do is
need you need to send money to Tommy
John you know it's about that time last
call is happening and after they're
gonna lock up the cells I've got to get
back so you have to go back well I'm
gonna read the Bible say and say my
prayers and make sure that I do my part
to improve the world as much as I can as
a retired dog catcher and serial killer
you have a leg or take away Jerry
Quentin gray
I didn't mean to upstage her like that
that's all right yeah I need to meet you
upstairs tell the truth you're digging a
hole in the wall at yourself behind that
poster Rita Hayworth urchin no no no no
no I I don't want to escape earlier you
know she won't take me back and I don't
think I can find proper employment yeah
probably that that's better where I am
right now yeah you're being the best you
that you can be so you know I've got
I've got a lot of friends here a lot of
friends here yeah yeah of course they
admire you well I wouldn't say that but
[Laughter]
I helped them and they helped me oh I
got ya
go ahead Jerry thank you well like
Dennis said like Dennis said it you can
go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
whatever
reason that's fine too you can go to our
blog 13 o'clock podcast wordpress calm
and there's a little button in the side
part sidebar where you can go to a
PayPal account if you'd like tape a
one-time donation just like Melanie -
sometimes again thank you don't have
sexual problems yeah it's alright and
remember to check out all of our
products over at ours as well store
zazzle.com / 13 o'clock podcast we have
lots of cool shirts and glasses and
pillows and all kind of fun [ __ ] so go
check them out also go check out a big
game crafter and go to my site called
giallo games GI a ll o and i have three
different games there with some
expansion packs for two of the games you
want to check those out all kind of like
murder mystery type games I feel like
that type of thing and that'll do it for
our latest episode about serial killer
Dean Corll episode 138 and take it away
Dennis Rader I just like to save the
bottle are you people okay thank you for
listening to the show and the next all
prop you'll see me around boy you'll see
you out I'm I'm looking forward to it
I'm looking forward to it I'm looking
forward to it too thank you
Thank You Jenny you're very welcome this
able to see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]